we're going to turn to our border panel
which includes tom homan fox's
contributor and former acting ice
director under president trump as well
as arizona's attorney general mark
brnovich who has been fighting the
surging numbers particularly there in
yuma but tom let's begin with you this
year-end ice deportation report the
department telling fox it's you know not
being held up it's coming but what do
you make of it
well first of all shout out to bill
mollugen he's doing such a great job
down there we're going to get him an
emmy this year that's what we're going
to work on but look you the the ice
report griff i i was the third in
command ice in the unit oversaw the
production that report every year then i
became the ice director who actually
approved that report i can tell you
without a doubt that they had those
numbers mid-october
and we would usually release it within a
month however these numbers are so bad i
promise you the department of homeland
security and the white house are trying
to figure out how they want to spend
these numbers how they going to support
biden's open border strategy when they
see these numbers that are devastating i
can tell right now compared to the last
year under trump administration removals
are going to be down almost 90 percent
the removal of criminal aliens are going
to be down at least 65 percent despite
the fact that joe biden and the
secretary said we're going to
reprioritize ice priorities to
concentrate on more criminals this these
numbers going to show they're removing
less criminals so this report this it's
been they had the numbers for a while
they're just trying to figure out how
we're going to spend it and what here is
my guess they're going to report it
different than reported in the last
decade because they don't want to be
able to compare this report to previous
reports because it's going to be
embarrassing
mr attorney general as you heard from
tom in bill's report he says that this
administration is uh unsecuring the
border purposely you have a crisis right
now in yuma arizona particularly you saw
the two sex offenders just apprehended
this week what are you doing in arizona
to address it and do you believe the
administration is doing this on purpose
griff i think that the best evidence of
someone's intention is what they
actually do and i think unequivocally as
a prosecutor you look what the bite
administration's done is they are
systematically dismantling our border at
one point i thought they wanted to
just or get rid of ice but it's clear
they just want to get rid of our whole
southern border because they have
allowed the cartels to seize operational
control and i sit here and i think to
myself like think about this the story
just before this was about novak
djokovic the greatest tennis player in
the world can't get into australia and
let and yet the bite administration has
allowed more than 2 million people to
illegally enter our country and actually
spread them throughout our entire
country and meanwhile the cartels have
seized control we have a record amount
of fentanyl heroin flooding into our
country and all of us are paying for
this not only in our taxes but we're
also paying this with the safety of our
communities and with our precious lives
tom i want to
bring you back to you know mr attorney
general bernadette's there saying that
this unprecedented number coming across
in the rgb sector alone the number of
sources gave me this morning more than
13
156 known godaways what does this mean
for our not just southern border but for
the nation in terms of security
well look i'm glad you brought that
question up because this isn't just
about illegal immigration i don't care
what your opinion is on illegal
immigration this is about public safety
because border patrol's arrested over 12
000 criminals convicted criminals so how
many of the half a million almost 500
000 got aways based on camera traffic
based on sensor traffic and drone
traffic that bourbon should respond to
how many of five thousand uh 500 000
were criminals or gang members and also
border patrols already arrested 16
people on fbi screening database
how many of that 500 000 are known
suspected terrorists we don't know but
i'm afraid someday we're going to find
out so this isn't this is just as an
illegal immigration problem it's a
public health crisis for the covet it's
a public safety crisis and there's a
national security crisis of huge
proportions well tom they know how many
have hit the tsdb terror screening
database they won't tell us they say
they can't for national security reasons
i asked that question quite a lot tom
holman mr attorney general mark bernice
thank you very much for your time we've
run out of time we'll continue to follow
this very important issue thanks sir